on passe aux invités du soir on va
revenir sur ce drame euh qui touche de
nombreux Français de confessions juives
insulte menace ou encore tag sur leur
maison euh et dans un instant Nura
Élisabeth gardienne d'un immeuble dont
les murs ont été tagués avec des étoiles
de David qui sera avec nous et vous
entendrez alors vraiment vous allez
entendre le témoignage de Lucy euh qui
est vraiment bouleversant qui a subi tag
insulte et agression antisémite regardez
euh ce qui a été trouvé regardez c'est
faux ce reportage regardez dans ce
quartier de saint-toin en scène
Saint-Denis des étoiles de David
symboles de la religion juive ont été
déposées au pochoir sur les murs d'une
maison le CRIF dénonce une succession
alarmante d'acte antisémite il nous
donne l'impression d'être monté dans une
machine à remonter le temps et de se
retrouver dans les années 39 où ben on
déclarait que la chasse aux Juifs était
ouverte des étoiles de David identiques
ont été signalées sur un bâtiment à ici
les Moulineau et sur des maisons à
aubervillier ces trois dernières
semaines plus de 800 actes antisémites
ont été
recensé ça c'est des images qu'on
croyait plus jamais revoir ça a été dit
ce matin on s'est tous réveillé avec ces
images et vraiment Gilles ça a été bah
c'est un choc terrible on n pas connu
les les années 30 mais ça rappelle la
chasse au juifs il faut le dire quoi la
stigmatisation vous êtes là on vous a
reconnuant moi je vais vous dire un truc
moi quand quand la semaine dernière il y
eu un boycott TPMP croyez que c'est pas
un acte antisémite ça bien sûr vous
croyez quoi moi je vous le dis moi oui
oui dis c'est un acte antisémi j'ai j'ai
même vu des gens qui cherchaient les
sociétés où j'avais des des pars pour
les boycotter je je v vous dire là il se
passe tout ce qu'il faut pas faire non
je vais vous dire on on on va on fait
tout ce qu'il faut pas faire et on est
en train dealler vers une dérive qu'on
redoutait tous je vais vous dire il y a
même des artistes qui nosent même plus
venir sur le plateau parce qu'il disent
on va me demander mon avis sur le
problème au Proche Orient et cetera donc
là on est en train de tout mélanger et
euh je vais vous dire euh là nous et je
pense la France tous les Français euh on
est dans un pays extraordinaire la
France c'est un pays exceptionnel et les
Français sont exceptionnels je suis
désolé les Français ils sont
exceptionnels et les Français ils ont
fait qu'on puisse qu'on a on a pu vivre
ici tous ici une vie incroyable et
aujourd'hui on est en train d'attiser la
haine de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
alors qu'au contraire tous les Français
on devrait être uni pour que on avance
vers la paix ça s'arrête je veux vous
dire c'est pas parce qu'on va le faire
que ça va arriver mais moi ce que
j'aimerais au lieu de voir des
manifestations d'un côté et de l'autre
moi ce que j'aimerais voir c'est voir
des Français toutes les confessions oui
avec un drapeau israélien un drapeau
palestinien et qu'on puisse faire une
marche voilà VO pour la paix voilà la
paix ici a défaut d'être la pai làb ex
parce que la paix là-bas on y arrivera
pas nous en tout cas nous à notre
échelle on n arrivera pas c'est pas nous
qui allons faire la paix là-bas mais par
contre on peut faire la guerre ici et
c'est ce qui se passe actuellement donc
faisons la paix ici
et quand je vois des des des des gens
sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont des comportements mais
inadmissible j'étais pour les réseaux
sociaux maintenant je ne le suis plus
sachez-le je trouve qu'il y a une dérive
incroyable depuis ce conflit et je vous
dis aujourd'hui il faudrait qu'on fasse
tous une marche vraiment h tous ceux qui
veulent et le plus nombreux possible
parce que je pense qu'ici tous sur ce
plateau moi j'ai j'ai pas un pote juif
qui me dit je veux pas d'état
palestinien bah oui j'ai pas un pote
musulman qui me dit je veux la
destruction d'Israël et l'anéantissement
d'Israël ouis donc alors oou mes potes
sont tous cons ou tous les gens que je
cottoi sont des abrutis ou bien bien les
abrutis sont sur les réseaux j'ai
peut-être ma petite idée je pense que
les abrutis sont sur les réseaux donc ne
vous laissez pas influencé par les
réseaux c'est comme la semaine dernière
je vous dis aussi ils ont fait une
fausse rumeur comme quoi l'émission
était boycottée l'émission va très bien
mais ça c'est pas le problème on s'en
fout de l'émission je vous dis on s'en
fout ce qu'on voit c'est la haine sur
les réseaux il faut pas qu'elle se
déplace dans la vie et dans la vie de
tous les jours moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui avec tous mes potes on n pas
ch
et on veut tous la même chose ça se
calme et qui est la paix on est autant
touché quand on voit des familles
massacrées par le Hamas que des civils
palestiniens et le petit qui qui
reconnaissez sa famille je vous le dis
le mec qui est pas qui est insensible à
ça c'est que c'est il a rien à faire ici
rien à faire sur terre un mec qui soit
qui est insensible ou qui est pas
insensible ni à ce que j'ai dit sur les
familles israéliennes il a ce que j'ai
dit sur ce petit je l'ai vu cette vidéo
j'ai regardé une quinzaine de fois où ce
petit all reconnaître sa famille tous
les corps de sa famille il a perdu toute
sa famille je vous le dis donc
aujourd'hui quand je vois des
manifestations
proalestiniennes grand plaisir je vois
des manifestations pro-israéliennes avec
grand plaisir mais il faudrait aussi
qu'on fasse peut-être une manifestation
ici pour la paix en France parce que
c'est inadmissible ce que je vois sur
les réseaux et quand j'ai mes potes com
j'ai mes potes musulmans ou juifs qui me
disent cyil en ce moment c'est compliqué
de faire des plateaux qu'ils ont peur de
venir à parler à la télévision et qu'ils
ont même qui ont même peur de dire je
suis pour la paix parce que quand ils
disent qu'ils sont sur la paix mes potes
musulmans ils se font défoncer mes potes
juifs ils se font défoncer aussi donc je
vous dire quand on arrive à ce point de
rupture à un moment faut dire STOP il
faut arrêter il faut dire on arrête les
conneries et on arrête d'être influencé
par 1000 abrutis sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'ils sont pas plus hein et il
teetent beaucoup et ici je le
redis ici on fera on ser on essaiera
toujours d'être le plus juste possible
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
maintenant ce que je vois sur les
réseaux je vous dis c'est inadmissible
les mecs qui viennent mê nous menacer
devant le studio c'est inadmissible ça
ça doit plus arriver je vous dis ça doit
plus arriver parce que c'est pas la
bonne solution et je vous dis importez
la guerre ici ça règlera pas le conflit
là-bas bien au contraire en
revanche faire la pai être dans une paix
comme on a toujours été ici dialog tout
ça et dans le dialogue et de se dire on
mine de rien on veut tous la même chose
et ben ça fera peut-être ça fera
peut-être pas la paix là-bas mais au
moins ici les choses se calmeront et on
pourra euh voilà arrêter d'écouter des
abrutis sur les réseaux sociaux qui font
passer des messages de haine et qui font
qu'aujourd'hui euh je vous dis c'est
insupportable d'aller sur les réseaux
sociaux moi j'y vais pas du tout donc
vous pouvez continuer à m'insulter je
m'en fous total les réseaux sociaux j'y
vais jamais donc continue à m'insulé je
vois je suis en hashtag ce soir je vais
être encore en tté mais je m'en fous
total hein Anouna en TT j'ai l'habitude
je pense que je suis le mec le plus en
tté de France donc continuer mais vous
feriez mieux de faire une marche tous
ensemble je vous le dis avec un drapeau
israélien et un drapeau palestinien et
je pense que ça fera beaucoup plus
avancer le chose que vos conneries sur
les réseaux et les insultes et les
menaces et cetera d'accord arrête de
menacer il d arrêtez de menacer arrêtez
de faire les malins sur les réseaux
sociaux arrêtez tout ça pensez plutôt à
une paix durable et peut-être ici et et
ne mélangez pas tout je vous dis
personne les gars et arrêtez de faire
croire que vous connaissez sur le
conflit sur les bouts des doigts et vous
connaissez exactement la situation la
seule chose qu'on veut tous c'est un
État palestinien un état israélien
souverain pour les deux aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est tout ce que tout le
monde veut mais quand je vois des
abrutis qui appelle à la destruction
quand je vois mort aux Arabes sur
Twitter ou mort aux Juifs je vous dis
ces garsl pour moi c'est inadmissibles
qui sont encore sur les réseaux sociaux
on doit avoir leur adresse alleer les
chercher et je peux vous dire moi ils
vont passer 3 jours en cellule ils vont
comprendre ce que c'est je ve vous dire
ou peut-être même pas 3 jours 3 mois
parce que c'est beaucoup plus qu'il faut
un mec qui dit mort aux Arabes ou mort
aux Juifs pour moi il prend un an de
tôle ferme voilà je vous le dis c'est
c'est aujourd'hui c'est comme ça donc ça
je ça je veux pas le voir moi sur les
réseaux quand je vais sur les réseaux
tous les matins et que je vois ce genre
de message vous dis j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de me dire il faut arrêter ces
réseaux de de merde qui font qui ne qui
ne vraiment qui ne diffusent que de la
haine merci en tout cas à vous d'être
avec nous ellisabeth meres vous êtes
gardienne d'un immeuble qui a été tagué
oui c'est vous qui avez découvert les
tags non moi quand je sortais le matin
mes poubelles comme
d'habitude je vois ça personnellement
j'étais choquée bien sûr vous êtes dit
vous êtes dit quoi tout de suite moi
quand j'ai sorti je je je n'arrivais pas
à bouger c'était même un voisin qui m'a
appelle il me dit t'inquiète je vais
appeler la police parce que je
resté excusez-moi un peu choqué c'est
normal nor je suis portugaise je ne suis
pas ni juif ni quoi que ce soit c'est ça
et et vous êtes regardez come vous êtes
ému ça oui c'est il y a beaucoup de
familles de confessions juifes dans
votre immeuble ben pas autant que ça bah
dans mon immeuble on a de tout vous
voyez c'est un immeuble ça fait 23 ans
je suis là c'est c'est un immeuble quand
on s'entend tous on fait des fêtes
ensemble on n jamais parlé de politique
de quoi que ce soit ni des religions et
on sait chacun on sait ce qu'on est et
franchement on est très très bien
et et et voilà quoi ça voilà comme
Monsieur dit là je suis pour la paix et
bien sûr et est-ce que tous les gens là
qui voient en France là qui voient ce
qui se passe actuellement là madame elle
a dit moi je je suis pas concerné mais
mais je suis ému et vous avez peur oui
voilà par contre
oui la France et et les Français je le
dis 85 % des Français ont peur heinage
d'jourd'hui Françis sont des gens
exceptionnels et je le redis parce que
je le vois moi mon public je le vois
tous les gens qui viennent là tous les
soir ils veulent ils veulent pas
d'histoire ils veulent ils veulent être
tranquill c'est des gens qui travaillent
qui font leur trucs qui qui on ils ont
déjà eu ils ont déjà eu le covid ils ont
eu euh ils ont eu les on on se rappelle
de la période des gilets jaunes euh vous
croyez quoi parce que là en ce moment on
ne parle que de ça ouis donc forcément
tous les autres problèmes ils sont sous
le tapis vous croyez que les
agriculteurs il galèrent pas en ce
moment vous croyez que les familles
elles arrivent à vivre normalement et
qu'elles arrivent à boucler leur fin de
mois et tu comme je disais la la
situation économique elle a pas changé
et il y a des mecs le 15 du mois et ben
ils ont pas pour nourrir leurs enfants
et il y a Noël qui arrive là il y a des
parents qui va arriver dans dans un mois
dans 2 mois qui sont comme ça parce
qu'ils disent je vais pas pouvoir offrir
de cadeaux à mes enfants voilà encore
cette année donc là comme l'actualité
euh c'est
essentiellement ce conflit et ben
forcément on nous oublie tous les autres
conflits on oublie tous les autres
problèmes et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire qu'il y a des Français qui ont
énormément de problèmes les autres
conflits on oublie aussi
les par plus il y a Lucy qui n'a c'est
pas son vrai prénom elle a pas voulu
venir ce soir mais on l'a eu en audio
écoutez bien son témoignage elle a été
victime de choses très graves tag
insulte et même agression physique à
caractère antisémiteelle vient d'abord
sur les tags abominable qui ont été
inscrit devant sa porte à plusieurs
reprises devant la porte de chez elle
écoutez je me réveille à la veille de
your je vois marquer Mor au Juif sur ma
porte 2 jours après j'enlève Mor au Juif
j'essayieenlever une deuxième fois j'ai
eu un autre tag 2 jours après une croix
gamée les Juifs gazé j'étais en état de
choc c'est mon infirmier qui m'a
réveillé parce que j'ai un infirmier qui
vient 5 fois par jour pour des insulines
donc il est venu il m'a dit regardez ce
qui est sur la porte et j'ai dit
qu'estce qu'il a sur la porte porte j'ai
vu j'ai dit ça y est ça va recommencer
ça y est ça va recommencer et je suis
tombée il a essayé de me rattraper j'ai
perdu
connaissance voilà voilà il y a des gens
qui sont incroyables sur Twitter
regardez Boujard voilà lui ça c'est
voilà parce qu'il y a des gens bien sur
titeur qui dit Anouna juif oui alors je
suis musulman oui alors l'humain
n'est-il pas fait de la même chair et du
même sang à méditer c'est des messages
de Pai mais c'est très rare quand on
voit vous allez entendre ça alors Lucy
elle a ici était aussi agressé
physiquement frappé elle se fait cracher
dessus et aujourd'hui elle ne sort plus
de chez elle ça ça se passe en France
rendez compte en 2023 bientôt 2024
écoutez bien ce témoignage qui est
effroyable la voisine d'as j'ai fait un
peu de bruit elle est montée elle m'a
ditarrête de faire du bruit elle m'a
attrapé elle m'a sorti dehors elle m'a
jeté par terre j'ai un handicap à 80 %
elle m'a jeté par terre m'a tapé j'ai
connis la tête contre le placard j'avais
une
bosse
c'est terrible c'est terrible
franchement c'est terrible et etlas elle
n'est pas la seule aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui sont protégés et
heureusement qu' sont protégés mais
parce qu'ils sont juifs vous vous rendez
compte en France il y a des gens qui
sont sous protection il y a des villes
parce queil y a eu C ces ces étoiles de
David poché en bleu sur de nombreuses
communes 14e arrondissement de Paris des
communes en Bonlieu parisiennees même en
province et bien la police parfois dit
aux gens vous avez été identifiés ne
sortez pas mais où on est quoi et ils
ont raison faut protéger les gens mais
qu'on en soit là c'est désespérant ce
que vous dites alors pour luici les
choses sont claires si elle est agressée
de la sor c'est uniquement parce qu'elle
est juive et elle a très peur de la
suite
écoutz juif en 2023 j'ai peur de que ça
recommence comme la chir mon fils il m'a
dit tu ne sors pas maman si je dois
venir te chercher tu attends que
j'arrive et tu descends je monte moi te
chercher j'ai des visites chez le
cardiologue et tout les infirmiers il
pour venir me chercher ils savent que
j'ai peur je descendre toute seule je ne
sors plus toute seule c'est fini à
chaque moment j'ai peur
elle nous dit également qu'elle veut
déménager puisque les agressions les
agresseurs ont proposé une solution à
Luc pour tout arrêter la
conversion on m'a dit tu veux la
tranquillité alors convertis-toi à
l'Islam et là tu seras tranquille on te
fout la paix il m'ont dit tant que tu
auras pas la conversion et ben on
continuera à te harceler je veux
déménager mais le problème c'est qu'on
donne pas de logement ça fait quelques
années que ça du on me le promet mais
personne ne bouge
personne personne ne veut bouger
personne si vous nous rejoignez à 21h3
le témoignage de Lucy euh na changé son
prénom victime de tag insulte et même
agression physique à caractère
antisémite vous allez voir la suite est
est incroyable euh après elle n'est pas
un cas isolé hein c'est vrai que que les
les Juifs de France ont très très peur
tous enfin moi je je leur j'en parle je
parle à quelquesun
ils changent leur nom sur les les
plateformes genre uber d
verou ils enlèvent les mesouas parce
qu'ils sont paniqués il ils ont peur
c'estàd qu'ils ont l'impression d'avoir
une cible dans le dos et ils ont une
peur panique moi je dire je je vais vous
dire je pense que les réseaux sociaux
ont une part de responsabilité immense
dans ce qui se passe actuellement dans
l'hystérie pour moi ils ont la plus
grosse part de responsabilité je vous le
dis et c'est un fléo les réseaux sociaux
sont devenus un fléo dans ce cas précis
et je le redis arrêtez de menacer sur
les réseaux sociaux arrêtez de je ne
veux on veut plus voir de morts aux
Arabes de morts aux Juifs sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est c'est
intolérable alors il faut qu'il fasse
passer une loi pour les réseaux sociaux
le gars qui dit mort aux Arabes et qui
est tranquille derrière son ordinateur
sait pas qui c'est et il faut des
semaines et des semaines pour savoir qui
c'est il faut faire une demande qui est
extrêmement contraignante pour le
retrouver ce gars-là moi je vaux pouvoir
le retrouver en une heure et aller chez
lui aller le chercher chez lui le gars
qui a dit mort aux Arabes ou le gars qui
a dit mort aux Juifs et m'en occuper
directement avec la police je vous le
dis voilà parce que c'est inadmissible
et je vous le dis les réseaux sociaux
c'est eux qui foutent la merde sachez-le
ils sont en train de une merde
monstre
et pourquoi pas faire une journée sur
les réseaux sociaux parce que qui dirige
les réseaux sociaux même en France les
gars on les entend jamais alors ils sont
bien contents ils se gavent hein ils
c'est El masque qui veut pas
bien sûr non non mais je ouiors des
idé Arab juif c'est la liberté
d'expressionass une journée il devrait
lancer des journées que des tweets avec
des drapeaux palestiniens israéliens
voilà que des tweets comme ça pourquoi
il fait pas une journée comme ça même
sur les réseaux sociaux pourquoi il
lance pas une journée voilà tous les
tweets qui seront à
caractère antisémite anti
antimusulmanans ou des gars qui disent
on veut la destruction d'Israël on veut
la destruction de la Palestine on les
enlève on veut veut que des tweets avec
les deux drapeaux et des tweets de paix
pourquoi ils font pas une journée de
paix sur les réseaux sociaux ça ça ça ça
ça aa un retentissement voilà ça ils
prennent un jour ils disent voilà bah
vous savez quoi la semaine prochaine et
ben le dimanche c'est où voilà où les
gens ont le plus le temps et ben vous
faites une journée et ben vous savez
quoi on fait la Journée de la Paix sur
Twitter parce que ce qu'on lit sur
Twitter je vous le dis c'est que de la
ha et je vous le dis ça donne des idées
et les gars ils voient des tweets il voi
des trucs qui sont passés ils disent bah
tiens ça nous donne des idées pour faire
des choses h ça c'est pas possible ne
croyez pas le gars qui est venu devant
le devant le devant le studio c'est un
gars qui a eu des trucs sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que tout est déformé tout
est on sait même pas moi j'ai j'ai lu
des articles qui disaient boycotte t PMP
il aurait pu finir par parce qu'on a
parce qu'on a boycotte TPMP parce qu'on
a condamné l'attentat terroriste du 7
non mais les gars non mais on on est où
là on marche sur la non parce que les
gens disent qu'on condamne pas les
bombardements à Gaza mais bien les a
toujours condamné les bombardements donc
les gens nous disent G nous disent oui
mais vous avez fait le 7 octobre tout un
cinéma mais maintenant il y a Gaza
c'est c'est les mot qu'on parce que les
gens pensent que c'est la France qui va
régler le problème moi ce que je pense
vraiment la France elle peut rien
fairei que c'est TPMP qui va régler le
problème c'est pas TPMP c'est pas la
France la France peut rien faire elle va
pas y aller toute seule elle peut rien
faire et les mecs te disent oui vous
avez fait le 7 oct mais on on condamne
aussi ce qui se passe en ce moment on a
demandé des cesser le feu on condamne ce
qui se passe à Gaza faut êre faut être
nul pour pas frens qu'on toutes les
idées que j'ai dit là le ministre du
numérique j'aimerais bien l'appeler bah
qu'il le fasse ça cette Journée de la
Paix sur Twitter il trouve un accord
avec Twitter je peux vous dire avec
l'oseille qui prennent hein Twitter et
insta et cetera je peux vous dire il
faut que les ministres il les mettent au
pas je vous le dis parce que je sais
même pas où il payent des impôts ceuxl
d'ailleurs sans doute pas en
France le pouvoir le pouvoir n'est pas
du côté du ministre pour le moment donc
il faut renverser tout ça il faut qu'il
ait des leviers et qu'il agissent les
leviers c'est l'oseille hein crois-moi
le levier c'est toujours l'oseille
croismoi surt avec des gens comme ça je
te le dis bah il faut taper au
portefeuille et quand tu vas leur dire
on va vous mettre une taxe à Twitter ou
insta qui va les mettre KO tu vas voir
s'ils vont pas le faire ça je te le dis
parce qu'à un moment il faut arrêter
d'être gentil aussi avec ces gars-l à un
moment ça suffit et ce qui est
insupportable c'est la passivité c'est
le fait que personne ne réagisse toi tu
appel à une journée de de paix une une
marche pour la paix c'est des choses
qu'on a déjà vu en France ve voir des
gars je veux voir des gars
avec paltinen dans une mais à tous les
niveaux à tous les niveaux il y a plein
d'initiatives qui pourrai être faites
c'est c'est terrifiant ce bégement de
l'histoire et cette passivité le fait
que rien que personne ne dise rien
encore plus important pour moi la
Journée de la Paix sur Twitter que même
dans la rue je vous le dis ça c'est un
c'est tter mer vous savez bien que
l'algorithme de Twitter n'e n'aime que
le clash et c'est pour ça c'est tant
qu'on
auraon
profond avec l'oseille qui prennent pour
une journée il peent mettre derrière tu
peux empêcher un mec dans son salon
d'être un se soldat israélien ou un
soldat palestinien avec son iPhone 15 tu
peux pas l'empêcher il veut faire des
révolutions dans son salon en pantoufle
pe demander au population d' un plus
responsable les gens veent parler tu
pouras t'empêcher par contre la marche
là c'est très intelligent et c'est
mieux yine je me souviens vous avz dit
que c'était
impossible moi j'aimerais bien que les
gens qui font ça il regardent des des
vrais documentaires sur la choix et qui
prennent des cours d'histoire qui se
rendent compte de ce que ça a été les 6
millions de Juifs qui sont morts dans
des vont
répondre j'ai une proposition à faire r
j'ai une proposition à faire j'ai une
proposition à faire j'ai une proposition
à faire au service public je leur
demande de diffuser tous les films de
Rotman de rediffuser le pianiste de
rediffuser tous les grands films et tous
les grands documentaire qui apprendront
aux jeunes ce qu'a été la Choa et
comment a été la montée de
l'antisémitisme et ce que
l'antisémitisme du 19e siècle a fini par
donner au début du 20e et
ensuite et ensuite avec
réond y a un problème dans ce pays c'est
que je pense que je pense que les gens
qui font ça ne savent pas ce qu'ils font
on on a reçu la dernière fois un
professeur ici qui dit lui-même que les
professeurs sont obligés de se
restreindre de ne pas apprendre RER
oui qu'on VI sur Lucy Lucy qui nous dit
que le plus allucinant dans l'affaire
dans C affaire Lucy qui veut déménager
qui est voilà qui qui qui qui vit des
moments incroyables la pauvre victime
tag insulte même agression physique à
caractère antisémite elle dit que malgré
les preuves et les émolements concrets
la police ne peut apparemment rien
faire la police ne veul pas prendre les
plaintes de voisinage ils m'ont coupé il
y a une semaine deux fois le fil
d'Internet j'ai été il m'ont dit on peut
pas c'est du voisinage on sait pas c'est
qui donc tant que c'est du voisinage on
peut rien faire rien du tout je suis
fatiguée je peux plus je suis en
dépression je peux plus j'arrive plus
que je demande un appel au secours c'est
tout qu'on m à sortir d'ici je peux plus
elle envoie un message à faire passer au
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron écoutez tu puisse nous protéger
surtout nous donner une sécurité parce
qu'on a aucune sécurité aucune parce que
tout simplement on est juif et le mot
juif ne leur convient pas on se fait
agresser il vient et c'est tout sans
plus les gens n'ont rien du tout
derrière voilà euh merci à Lucy pour son
témoignage merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous et merci à vous tous on se retrouve
demain
merci